obviously the the the minor details make
the big details so
set plays we we've been solid and um
of course it's a big plus the most
important thing is winning games and
keeping clean sheets enables us to do
that
looking back at the last game against
denmark in the nations league
how do you look back on that time when
england lost and you got sent off and
perhaps you weren't
having your most i suppose a brilliant
time on and off the pitch
how do you look back on that and the
support network that you had in place
yeah great support around me i have
great family i have great friends
um a great club as well who's helped me
along the way as well so um
i look back obviously it was a
challenging time i think
every international player has been
through ups and downs in the career
that's part and parcel of being a
footballer so
yeah it was a challenging time but i'm
proud of the the way that i handled it
and the way that i come through it and
now i'm in a positive place and yeah
everything's good at the moment and long
may continue
is it extra motivation because you lost
last time out and and because you got
sent off
not that you need any motivation in the
semi-final for of a european
championships of course
yeah i wouldn't say i wouldn't say it's
extra motivation because of that i think
the motivation is there it's the
semi-final of the european championship
um the semi-final of losing at the world
cup
a lot so we need to make sure when it
comes on wednesday night that we get a
positive feeling rather than the one
that we got against croatia
just a word on the fans because you
enjoyed euro 2016 as a fan so
you're aware of what it means to the
supporters when an england team delivers
are you aware of the euro fever that's
gripping the country at the moment or
have you
been able to keep yourself inside your
bubble
no of course we're aware of it it's um
it's brilliant to see
and that's what social media should be
there for and that's what
it's there for at the moment we see all
the positive vibes and the videos going
around
and yeah like i say it's um
it's a great atmosphere to be involved
in and winning football matches enables
that
um but yeah we're on this journey
together us players staff
fans we're all in this together we all
want the same thing we want to win
football matches and we want to go as
far as we can and
at the moment everything's good there
seems to be a quiet confidence about
this england side that they truly
believe
that winning this competition is
possible how has that happened
i think through the hard work since um
our defeat to croatia
every game that we've played we've tried
to improve on every game in this
tournament we feel like
we're improving we're getting better i
think we can still get better
and i think we will do um but yeah i
think the belief's there we have a we
have a great
great group exceptional talent um and
and some great leaders and
some great experience too so it's a good
mixture but we're not getting carried
away we've got
a lot to do and a lot to improve on and
just finally a note on the fact that
there's
so many manchester united players
already in this england side
another one has just been added in jaden
sancho did you
uh have to try and convince him to sign
for manchester united and what'd you
make of that signing
yeah first and foremost jayden's a a top
player exceptional talent a young lad
with a lot of experience and
um his numbers speak for itself what
he's done over in germany so
no he's a great player i don't think
it's a done deal yet
we can't confirm he's a manchester
united player i know it's close but
it's still a dortmund player as it
stands so but no of course
that it's exciting times ahead and
hopefully we'll get it across the line
good luck for the match thank you very
much thanks jess and when i jump onto
zoom with a question from dan kilpatrick
from the standard
hey harry hello let me just ask you
about um chris powell he's been getting
some
love on social media for his goal
celebrations
um he seems like a really kind of
positive character in the camp can you
offer some insight into
to what chris is like no chris has been
brilliant around the camp i think
um positive energy
um i think in these camps some days when
when
when you're waiting for games and things
in between games you can do with that
positive vibe and
energy around the place and he brings
that he's he's been brilliant um
as a coach but also off the field as
well and yeah i think
he i've seen his goal celebrations and
he's really enjoying them but
i think you all need to remember that we
we're all huge england fans and
whether we're sat on the bench uh
coaching or sat
in the stand um not involved in the team
but
we're still massive england fans and we
all want to win win football matches
thanks dan thanks i'll go back in the
room to ollie foster bbc hi there harry
you're saying
you're not in a bubble you're aware of
the excitement
as we go into the final stretch you see
it everywhere
repeated from former players pundits
england will never have a better chance
do you take that on board do you believe
that as well
no i don't take that on board i think
england in the past have had great
chances
um but we're focused on ourselves i
think
the the mentality of this group is that
we we demand a lot from each other
we demand to win football matches and we
just focus on each game as it comes but
i think in the past we've had great
chances and
um the outcome hasn't been great so no
um like i say every game that we play is
a tough game at this level you need to
perform to your highest to make sure
that gives you the possibility of
winning the football matching at the
moment we're doing that
and like i say every game we take take
as it comes and we need to make sure we
perform well
you talk about the hurt from 2018 the
semi-final defeat there
do you feel that this group is in a
better place do you feel the same kind
of vibes
throughout the group going into this
game yeah i think we're in a lot better
place than what we was i think the
experience of
of that would have would have learned
from it and also the experience of the
games in between as well for example the
nations league so we've had
a lot of big games in that period to to
improve on
um a lot of time spent together in terms
of on the training pitch and
and friendlies and qualifiers so every
game that we play together we feel like
we're going to improve
um i think you've seen this tournament
during the games that
from the first uh to the ukraine game
there's been a lot of difference in
terms of
um the principles that we're demanding
from each other and
yeah i think um of course we're in a
better place now but like i say
we've still got a long way to go some
some exciting new faces in this squad
when you look at you know the
introduction of
phil foden jayden sancho jack greelish
is getting a look in but
the core of this team was the one that
was in moscow you've got jordan pickford
john stones alongside you kyle walker
raheem sterling
uh jordan henderson's still about and
and harry kane as well so you do feel
that that sort of spine of the team has
developed over the last three years and
to
into what it is now yeah definitely i
think um
in a team you've got to build it on
balance and a great mixture i feel like
at the moment we've got
obviously the young exceptional talents
that we've got in this country is great
to see and
they're all gonna have wonderful careers
so no i think it's important that we
keep the spine and the experience and
the leaders in the group and
at the moment the balance seems to to be
good um
and yeah i think we're all going in the
same direction we all want the same
thing
and and that's to to win football
matches and do our best to win the
tournament
how do you think gary southgate has
developed as a manager over the last
three years
well ever since i've made my england
debut i think gareth's been brilliant
for this team um he probably sits here
and
gives us all the applaud it says players
but we appreciate the job that he's
doing and the way that he sets us up and
his man management skills so no i i
can't speak highly enough of gareth and
and his coaching staff and and the way
that we he's gone about his business
over the last four years
i mean he's spoken about the work that
he puts in you know the late nights
doing every bit of analysis on the
opponent there must be just absolute
trust that however he sets you up on
wednesday night
is going to be the right way yeah of
course i think he's proven that over the
last few years now that
um as an england manager he's always are
to please everyone especially the public
in terms of
the way that he sets up and and the team
selection but
um we trust him that whatever team he
picks or whatever style of play he wants
to go with
um it's the best one for the job and
finally um
denmark and let's be honest if england
weren't still this far
we'd all be denmark fans wouldn't we i
mean their story over the past few weeks
has been
horrific to begin with and then
incredible and inspiring
they they are highly motivated on this
emotional journey that they're on
yeah definitely it's been really
inspiring their journey um
obviously first and foremost our
thoughts have always been with christian
and
in his recovery and we're all right
behind that
um and yeah they're a good team that
have proven now
for years that they're a top team i
think they're the highest ranked team
that would have played in this
competition um so we know that they're
they're a strong team with great leaders
in the team
um great experience so we know it's
gonna be a tough game but we're really
focused on ourselves
thanks thank you thank you thanks holly
back on zoom with mark man brian some
press association hi harry um you've
touched on it already but but last
summer was was a difficult time for you
personally um gareth stooped by you
publicly at that time even naming you in
his squad whilst things were still
in greece were still was still going on
he then obviously called you up to the
euros despite you
carrying an injury um firstly how much
does that support mean to you and
does it feel like delivering these euros
could be a way of almost paying back
that support
yeah gav support of me has been
brilliant ever since um i've made my
debut for
for england he picked me um to make my
debut
and then i think ever since i've been
available um
i've pretty much played in every game
possible so
that gives me great confidence and
belief and trust
going into the game and to enable me to
perform to my best and
of course every time i step onto the
pitch i'm trying to repay him
the faith and and the trust because
every time i go into the pitch i want to
do my best for
for the country thanks mark uh dan
solsby jones itv
hi harry hello um it's another one
actually about gareth southgate and i i
just wondered
if you can think of any specific moments
where he's he's really helped you maybe
i don't know in the last year or so
um i wouldn't say any specific moments i
think
there's numerous of them um lots of
conversations
um lots of texts and lots of phone calls
and then speaking to him when i'm coming
to camp and things he's always there to
help
he's part and parcel of being a
footballer the ups and downs i've spoke
about it if you
if you go it's impossible to go through
a career without having
bad moments mistakes um
so yeah of course um he can he can pass
on his experiences and the way that you
handle things
and i'm always open to to learn and
improve and how happy would you
be for him if you went all the way this
year
he talked as you said a lot about how
happy he'd be for all of you guys
yeah of course um i'd be so happy for
him i'd be so happy for everyone
involved in this country
that's that's that's the aim before the
tournament we wanted to win the
competition
he still remains the aim um and like i
say
we're on this journey together everyone
together we all want the same thing
and at the moment it's going well and i
hope it carries on
thank you thanks dan back to zoom with
simon evans from reuters
i already um just just going back to
when you got got the injury i mean
obviously it was quite
close to the tournament and it's worked
out well and you've made it
and everything's going great but what's
the time during that recovery or at the
start of it where you thought
you might be spending this summer
watching it on television and missing
out on all this was that was that a
genuine fear for you
well i think with any injury you're
always you don't know how you're going
to
recover you don't know the rehab you
don't know whether you're going to have
a setback
touch wood i haven't had any setbacks in
my rehab at the moment so
no it's all gone smoothly and it's all
gone to pa planning it's all gone
probably a little bit quicker than than
we all thought
um obviously to miss the europa league
final was disappointing and then i fully
set my sights on
on making the euro squad and i didn't
actually know which game
at that moment when i would be available
or or be able to be to play competitive
football at such a high level it's
it's not like i'm i'm getting thrown
into a a friendly match it's it's the
european championship so it's so
demanding
and the intensity of each game so where
it where where it's gone and where it's
been i think great credit to the medical
staff at
manchester united and england um for the
way that they went about everything and
the way that they pushed me every day
and and obviously i'm really proud of
myself in terms of
um the way that i push myself as well
thanks simon
back in the room james allen espn hi
harry um jamie carragher's written in
the telegraph today about how he
exchanged
messages with you after what happened in
greece i just wondered if you could tell
us your version of that and how much
that meant
to you for him to reach out yeah of
course i
there was one thing when when you um
go through bad moments you realize the
people who support you
and and jamie was one of um numerous
people and ex-players who got in contact
and and spoke with me
um obviously i'm not gonna read out what
was said and spoke about but no
obviously that that was great support
and it means a lot and
i think like i say during these bad
moments you you do realize the people
who
who are supporting you i'm sure gareth
was important in that period as well i
mean
did you fear for your international
career at any point
um no i never felt for my international
career i always felt like i had
something to bring and something to
offer and
i knew um without getting into too much
detail of what went off in the summer i
knew
where i stood on behalf of that so i
always knew what went off um
and yeah like i say i'm i'm totally over
it now i've moved on i've it was a tough
time for sure
but i moved on just finally on on gareth
um you
spoke glowingly about him um the fa's
chief executive mark bulingham is
talking about offering him a new
contract beyond
2022 presumably the players would like
to see him
sign that yeah of course we've all um
well i can only speak on behalf of
myself but i'm sure
everyone as well is is so happy with in
terms of coming to the england camps and
the way that he's made it so enjoyable
for everyone and
obviously winning football matches over
the last three years has really helped
that along as well so
no i like i say i can't speak highly
enough of gareth and what he's done for
myself personally and
the trust and faith that he's putting me
thanks good thank you thank you
thank you james plenty of hands raised
on zoom so we'll go next to murad ahmed
from the ft
hi harry um so i just wanted to ask
about
preparation a lot of the other players
have spoken about how well prepared they
feel they are
and you know it's some of this is kind
of
cutting edge stuff you doing breathing
techniques after games you've got
you know psychologists on hand and open
door policy
i was hoping that you might give us some
insight of what the preparation was like
say before the ukraine game you know
what do you go through reams of video
uh how do you get ready so that you kind
of know what to expect when you
when you get to the games well
i'd say one thing is that everyone
prepares it in a different way
some people like more videos some people
like more meetings
some people like to study the opposition
and opponents and
and some people like to be left alone
and really focus on themselves so
listen we're we're in a hotel for the
majority of the day
so if you don't prepare well there's
you're doing something wrong
um recovery pool
massage um analysis
um it's all there for us we have great
um
staff here at england um so yeah
we have everything um to help us improve
everything to make us prepared and like
i say we're in a hotel
from morning to night so um you have
plenty of time and your hands to do
those things
thanks murad go back in there into rob
harris
good luck for uh wednesday thank you and
you know you must find it pretty
miserable at times watching and growing
up as a fan
how how do you reflect on that period
then when england didn't really achieve
much and the fact being part of these
runs to the semi-finals now and what you
think
has helped to transform it all yeah i
think
first and foremost back-to-back
semi-finals in a major in major
tournaments is
is is a great achievement i spoke about
this the other night he's a it's a great
achievement from us
but at the moment we're here and um we
want to go further
that that's out that's our main that's
that that's our mentality that's our
focus
um during the past i don't really look
back and
and think of the miserable times i look
back and watching england and it was it
was great times during my childhood
um obviously some disappointing nights
and but when i look back and
supporting and following my country um
and no it's great it's always been great
times because i'm there watching my
idols
watching people who i looked up looked
up to when i was a young kid and
and putting the england shirt on with my
brothers and and playing in the garden
so no it's
it's always been good memories when i
look back and obviously
some disappointing ones in there but
when i look back it's always been fun
memories
thanks rob uh back online to mike minay
for bbc radio manchester
hi harry hello um as well uh best luck
for wednesday of course um can i
ask you about your manchester united
teammate luke shaw um a great return to
form for him this year
for club and country you play alongside
him for clubbing country what have you
noticed and the difference within him
this year that's made him so stand out
yeah i think um first and foremost
his ability um has always been there he
has great ability as
every attribute to be one of the best
left-backs in the world
um i'd probably say the the main
difference i i feel within luke is
his mentality in terms of pushing
himself and and really
demand the demands that he's putting on
himself now to
to not just be um not just be a six out
of ten
each each and every game and not play
comfortable to go and really push
push on and be himself and and go and
push himself to
to be the best player on the pitch
because there's no reason why he can't
do that
with all the attributes and ability that
he has
thanks mike uh next to carrie brown
being sports
hi harry hello um we're talking about um
you traveling as a fan during the year
the last euros um
how much is there a sense that you would
just actually love to be in the crowd
when you're scoring goals with this side
yeah i think when you see all the videos
um
and the atmosphere that it creates and
um
all my family and my friends obviously
they weren't in the stadium the the the
other day
so they they had a party back in
in sheffield uh so yeah it was um
it's it's always great following your
country it's always
i i had a great time in france um i know
the memories of
the results wasn't wasn't great but for
me to be out there with the fans and
and the passion um and for me to realize
how much it means to actually everyone
um nice it was great memories for myself
and
and a fantastic holiday i think a few of
us
probably bumped into your brothers and
your um your mates on tour
in uh russia while you're in camp and i
think vardy's got a lot of the credit
for the um
slab head nickname but i think it goes
back a bit further than that
who's who's responsible and to blame and
i know you're a manchester united
world-renowned star now but
is it even strange that you've got
italian studios
um trying to understand what the slab
had slab head title means and talking
about it
no i think i i think it actually does
does originate from
from vardy um and and from russia i
think he said it in an interview once so
he's just kept caught on from there
um and i i i can't say i've seen the
italians
news reports i don't i don't know what
was said or or what's being said on on
that behalf
thanks kerry uh next gets paul haywood
um harry there's a obviously an intense
kind of pressure with
um semi-finals it's because you're so
close and and yet so
far um different type of pressure kicks
in i mean you
the team is playing better and better
but you know what it's like to go out at
the semi-final stage
so do you have a particular you're going
to adjust your thinking your strategy
as a team to cope with that very
different pressure against um denmark on
wednesday
um my mentality will be the same my
mentality going into the game will
be win the football match um
we'll probably have a little bit more
belief going into the denmark game than
what we did in the croatia game
um it was a lot of we hadn't been to a
semi-final in
in so long as a country so the belief
wasn't there i'm sure
um the fans are believing more now um
but as players of course and
and staff and and everyone involved in
in the bubble we're all believing as
well and
we have great belief but we've got to
focus on ourselves like i say
we've got to focus on on a performance
we can't look after the result
um football's decided on big moments but
one thing that we can do is make sure
that
come on that semi-final we perform to
our best best of our ability and we give
absolute everything
thanks paul uh we'll take one last
question this live section that we're
from alex crook talk sport
hi harry hello um i wanted to ask you
about cash brush michael obviously
somebody that you know well and somebody
who's
earned a lot of praise in this
tournament for the character that he
showed after
the tragic events in the first game for
denmark but as a goalkeeper as well
is he going to be a big part of denmark
trying to
succeed against you well of course he's
he's one of the main players he's a
fantastic
player i think over the last few years
especially he's
his level of form has been remarkable um
he's a is a fantastic player and a great
leader um
the way that he handles himself on and
off the field um
so yeah i still speak to casper every
now and then um i won't be speaking and
speaking to him leading up to the game
but um
noise is is a great player and a top top
leader
thank you alex okay that concludes the
live section of this media conference
we'll now move on to a short section in
bargain until 10
30 pm there we have it england defender
harry maguire talking ahead of
wednesday's semi-final